hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the most interesting features of
lactancius's treaties on the anger of
God is that he's going to take a strong
stance on God not just having analogies
to emotions behaving in certain ways
like a person who feels something but
actually feeling certain emotions
certain affects effectsiones in Latin
and you know we don't necessarily have
to translate that as emotions we could
translate it as affects or affections
but it's pretty clear that lactancius
does think that God feels things that
are similar to what it is that we human
beings do feel and in chapter four
because this is scattered across the
work he's going to be you know
criticizing the school of epicurus and
he tells us that
there's you know anger in God and
kindness but the epicureans think that
that isn't the case so
God is Not inactive and that's one of
the key differences between
lactancius's point of view and that of
several others as well and that of the
epicureans the epicureans thought that
the gods basically don't do anything
that's why they're not affected by what
we human beings do that's why they're
actually blessed and lactancius is going
to say that you know God is Not inactive
he's involved in you know the
administration of the world he answers
prayers cares for things and he says
What happiness can there be in God if
he's always inactive being at rest and
unmovable happiness here is beatitudinal
blessedness is another way of
translating it and this is an affective
State God also has as he says
care Kura for things in general and also
in particular so there are you know you
could say intentionalities or
comportments that are involved there and
he says epicurus made a mistake that is
understandable
so what is it he says that being led
from the beginning by the probability of
a single opinion he necessarily fell
into the things which followed What was
the first opinion well anger's not
consistent with a character of God and
so then he bought into that and was
unable to refuse the consequences saying
that because one affection being removed
necessity compel them to remove from God
the other affections or emotions as well
so he goes on and he says he who is not
subject to anger is plainly uninfluenced
by some other ones right uh kindness
grazia he's also not affected by fear
matus in Latin Joy La titsia uh grief
mirror uh pity Missouri
this last one is very very important for
Christian thinkers because God is
depicted as feeling pity or compassion
for uh the miserable creators the misery
right so what is uh epicurus doing here
he's saying well God can't feel any of
these why not as lactancius puts it all
the affections have one system one
motion and the word there is commotio
and the idea is that there's like one
let's call it manifold for the emotional
states and if you're going to take away
one emotion you really have to eliminate
all the rest and lactancius doesn't buy
that in chapter five and six
he's going to consider a rival school
that of the stoics who do seem to think
at least according to lachtances that
God does feel
some emotions for example
um you know care or
exhibits goodness kindness to people but
he doesn't feel anger why not because
anger is a bad emotion it can't be good
in any respect and lactancius goes on
and says if God is not angry with the
MPS and the unrighteous it's clear he
doesn't love the pious and the righteous
so the error of those is more consistent
who take away both anger and kindness
the stoics are just being kind of
inconsistent and not only
is God angry and kind or God angry and
loving
God is Angry God becomes Angry God
exhibits anger lachtancia says precisely
because God is kind and this is in
chapter six he says it follows that God
is angry because he is moved by kindness
right so the exhibiting feeling anger is
not something opposed to kindness It's
actually intra intrinsically connected
with it now does this mean that God
would feel the entire
panoply of what we could call human
emotions well
if we look at chapter 15 we see that
lactancius thinks that there are some
emotions that will not be in God and so
once again he's taking epicurus as sort
of the uh opponent he says epicurus
opposes us and says if there is in God
the affection of Joy leading him to
favor and hatred influencing them to
anger so now we've got like four
different emotional states he must of
necessity have both fear and inclination
and desire and the other affections that
belong to human weakness now is this in
epicurus as Texas we have them uh No
this must be some lost Passage
now lactancia says this doesn't actually
follow there's no reason to think that
this is the case it does not follow that
he who is angry must fear
or that he who feels Joy must grieve in
short they who are liable to anger he
says are less timid in those who are of
a joyful temperament are less affected
with grief so even if we look at human
beings it doesn't follow that because a
person feels one emotion they must feel
all of the emotions some of the emotions
are actually kind of opposed to each
other and then he says um
we don't have to talk more about humans
let's talk about the Divine necessity
let's consider fear
why would God feel fear because God
would have to worry about something
greater than God that could damage God
or hurt God or something like that can
can that be the case he says you know
human beings are liable to all sorts of
problems right want injury pain death
but nothing can offer violence to God
not in a way that actually affects God
so God doesn't have fear
what about desire sexual desire
specifically libido
well I mean
the ancient Greek gods wanted to get it
on with each other and human beings but
you know the god of Christianity is a
sort of solitary thing and you could say
well what about the Trinity and okay
that that's true but the persons of the
Trinity don't want to screw each other
right he says that uh you know why do we
feel libido or sexual desire well it's a
way of reproducing the race
does God have to do that no there's no
female in whose Union he's able to
rejoice and he doesn't need succession
because he will live forever and ever
and then uh he talks about two other
emotions Envy Nvidia right why would God
be envious of anybody he doesn't need
anything that anybody has right uh and
then what's translated in this one is
Passion but we could look at it as
desire more generally or perhaps even
greed later on he's going to talk about
uh greed per se uh this desire for more
stuff which could be manifest in a
number of ways well God's got everything
God needs so God doesn't feel these
emotions right
then in chapter 16 uh there's a much
more thorough discussion about what it
is that God feels and why God feels it
and the you know very chapter of God and
his anger and affections the affectiones
so you know he goes on and he says that
it's not right that when God sees all
these wicked things that people are
doing he wouldn't be moved and arise to
take vengeance upon the wicked and
destroy the pestilent and guilty so as
to promote the interests of all good
people so why does God get angry why
does God punish I mean it's partly to
say oh you poor bastards you need to get
your your uh head straight and quit
doing all this stupid stuff but it's
also to protect the good
leaving them vulnerable to the wicked
would actually be a lack of kindness a
lack of care beneficence and anger are
intrinsically connected with each other
as we saw a little bit earlier and then
he also tells us that even in Anger
there is contained a showing of kindness
gratification right kindness both to the
the good but also kindness perhaps to
those who are being punished he goes on
and he says because there are some
affections to which God is Not liable as
desire fear avarice grief and envy right
so we see that there's a number of
different affections and the the avarice
is avaricio which is like the cupiditas
that we just discussed God doesn't have
these he's not subject to these affects
why not
because they are as lockedancius will
tell us vicious affections they are the
things that feed into vices vices bad
traits of character that in many cases
go to the very core or bottom of your
soul and so God isn't going to feel
those but then he goes on and he says on
the contrary those which belong to
virtue
uh those are things that God will feel
and what are these so
um anger towards the wicked in malos
Anger directed towards people who are
doing the wrong things people who are
bad right
but he also says love
towards the good or benefit however you
want to translate Caritas right which is
the Latin equivalent of Agape in Greek
this this love that flows out of God
karitas in Bonos
he also does feel one other that
lachtancius is going to highlight here
pity towards The Afflicted and notice
the choice of terminology here it's not
the usual Misericordia it's actually
miserazio which is it's got a sort of
sense of like God actually feeling
something towards them by way of
compassion in afflictus in the people
who are suffering right so God is
because God is virtuous because God is
just and good he will feel
certain emotions right he says in as
much as they are worthy of the divine
power he has affections of his own and
what are these These are both just and
true if he's not possessed to them the
life of human beings would be thrown
into confusion but God in fact does feel
these things and provides us with a kind
of example that we can follow of what it
would be like to have virtuous emotions
that is emotions which reflect and feed
into goodness truth and justice